I started playing guitar first before
singing I was 10 years old this is when
Justin Bieber was starting to come up on
YouTube and I had a lot of time like on
my hands so I was watching YouTube
videos of him playing guitar and singing
like just doing covers like right in the
beginning of his career and um I had a
guitar but I didn't know how to play it
so I was just like okay this gets
playing guitar let me see I can go do it
so I just grabbed my guitar and I was
like alright let me figure this out so
like I paused the video and I'd watch
his fingers and I'd look obvious finger
it's copy the strumming alright oh he's
playing something different pause it
would copy his fingers again and so like
it was just like a basic 4 chords over
and over and over again yeah and so I
was like ok like I got that down like
let me click on other video so click on
another video learned a different song
and so I was okay like this is dope I
was like I'm doing something with this
yeah and so it was one day my dad came
home from work and he seen me playing
and he was like wait destiny like what's
going on here and I'm like dad like
listen like I just learned this and I'm
playing it for him and he's like do you
know what you're playing and I was like
not really I was like oh he's not back
[Laughter]
but he was like now I don't know I'm
just copying what this kids doing on the
internet and he was like alright we'll
come here so he took me to his piano he
was like alright strum that chord and he
I would strum it and then he was like
are Edessa d that's a a that's a G and
so like once he would tell me like all
the chords it stucks in my head right
away and then I just was it became
addicting after that so I wanted to
learn so many more songs and then that's
when I got into piano - and this was
stuff I self-taught myself on piano and
how old were you just 10 dude like I was
I was a home schooled in 6th grade so
like I was just doing all that like
little homeschool yeah it was
independent study so I went to school
like like three times a week
yeah but like I still have a lot of time
on my hands I like finished my homework
hella early like every day and then I
would just work on it like all day so I
had a lot of time but um but yeah it's
pretty much how it went down and then I
just just started singing like I just
started singing so your parents never
brought up the music thing to you you
just started doing that on your own
my dad kind of threw it in there my dad
would buy me drum sets like every year
for Christmas and so I know how to play
drums too so I gotta play drums
you [ __ ] prints and [ __ ] god
what we should just like drop this [ __ ]
like it's all casual [ __ ] it's like yeah
bill I know how to do master oh god she
just started taking my pillow and start
making a crane out by the way I also do
this no come foo because I do okay but
my dad has always taught me like the
basic one two three yeah like taught me
how to count on B and stuff like that
but my dad was my parents were never the
type of parents to shove something down
my throat so like my parents bought me a
guitar and I wasn't interested and I
just like I was like no I don't think I
want to play it but um but they're like
okay like you don't have to like it's
right there you want it yeah what kind
of lifestyle is this is amazing it was
really just a random day I just was just
like no play guitar today just gonna
figure and then it was an instant an
instant love like I was like okay this
is crazy like I just got mad inspired I
was just like you know like nothing has
ever hit me this hard before then from
the moment that you started playing like
40,000 instruments and then you started
when did you start singing I said no I
started singing like around the same
time I learned guitar like I just
started singing like I just started
singing and then my dad like kind of
like noticed that I was getting like
kind of a little good and so since he
was worshipping I was like no he was
just like oh so you could sing no [ __ ]
eh I don't know your dad but sumi-e
still a [ __ ] so you can [ __ ] see
[ __ ]
as white he's from Chicago I'm only I'm
we're in LA right now so that's the type
of like a Mexican that I'm used to is
[ __ ] but anyways you just saw you sing
sing and play guitar and he was like why
don't you like sing this Sunday like or
not saying but like at least play guitar
like in front of congregation on Sunday
for church and I was like yeah like I
was like yeah I want to do it like
that'd be fun
and so you say you won't even scared
then either no I was like yeah that
sounds dope so I did it and then I said
then I was like the worship leader for
my youth group like when I was like 12
years old and so like I was doing that
picking songs every week and like I was
just leading me my guitar had a drummer
and a piano player and so like that was
everybody from a youth group it was just
always Church always Wow Church of music
yeah that's so [ __ ] crazy
once it when did you start writing music
then I was 16 I was 16 my writing yeah
they said you 19 million in long ago
yeah what the [ __ ] was the first song
that you wrote um the first time I wrote
it was actually a song called I never
thought and I posted it I co-produced it
with another producer from my hometown
and we posted it unlike iTunes and
Spotify and stuff co-produced x16 what
the [ __ ] am i yes you make me hate my
[ __ ] up reading right now but
continue so you co-produced at the age
of [ __ ] 16 your very first time what
was it about it was like it was about I
wrote it about a friendship that what
like a fall out like with one of my best
friends and like we were no longer
friends anymore so I just wrote it about
like like people just turning backs on
you and stuff like I never thought this
would happen
are you guys still friends till this day
no stupid-ass [ __ ] the [ __ ] guess you
lucked out it ho anyways I lie back
people up Sactown homie [ __ ] you so wait
what
so that's so interesting I feel like
usually when people write their first
song it's all you had it always has to
be about love or like falling in love
but your [ __ ] was about it was about a
friendship fall out like it was it could
have been about a relationship but like
I wasn't in a relationship
time so it was about a friendship so
like I wrote like a verse and it was
only like 20 seconds like I'm gonna
record it and post it on like Twitter
and just ask like my phone had like
probably like 500 followers on Twitter I
was like I'm just gonna ask and see if
they like it so I rebutted my put my
phone in the corner and I sang it along
with this beat that I found it was it
was a beat that I found on YouTube and
we couldn't use it so I had my homie I'm
like yo can we like reproduce this out
and then like yes we like reproduce the
beat um what made it obviously really
different but um I put the video up on
Twitter and I was like something I'm
working on let me know what you guys
think ends up blowing up so that like
added like extra motivation extra
confidence to finish the songs a
basically blown up house just like on
Twitter like I got hella clout like
people retweet in it commenting on it
saying like yo finish this is his fire
did it it uh and I was like okay they
like it they like it I was like I got to
do it so I ended up just rewriting or
writing the whole thing and I just is
that [ __ ] out for people to hear right
now it was about a year ago but well we
took it down but it's like a fans like
took the audio from it and like put it
on YouTube so like it's on YouTube of
course that was like your baby things
popped you know yeah that was my first
single like that I've ever like released
like independently that's [ __ ] yeah
how did that feel
it was freaking sick I think it was dope
like I just performed cover songs like
only like when I do like just like open
mics and stuff but like I had that one
song I was like alright and for this
last song it's my own I was like so I
just did it I released an acoustic
version for it - that's [ __ ] crazy
you know what's so refreshing about you
I think like once you I mean as you get
older you tend people tend to get worn
out by life right but whenever I see a
young person talk about like how they
came up which freak wasn't even that
long ago literally you're a [ __ ]
fetus to me you just hear just made and
then like watching you and just how you
speak about your personal story it's
very [ __ ] refreshing thank you
because I'm in an industry right now
where you know people they kind of
forget where they started from and how
fortunate the things that they get to do
now are right so they there's a lot of
complaints right so like people my age
like you know in there
you're 31:32 they they see all this that
that they have but they kind of take you
for granted a lot because they don't
realize where they came from
right so they maybe there's a musician
who started off it's like there was a
time when nobody [ __ ] with you and I
mean literally nobody [ __ ] with you I
mean you would make music as much you
want but not a single person would
listen but now sometimes you we kind of
get used to our own success that we kind
of forget to take a step back and be
like you know look at all the [ __ ] that
I have yes how's it feel for you
it's just it's really really dope just
cuz you know I come from Lodi and like
when I started doing music everyone like
I would just post YouTube videos and on
Facebook
I like videos on Facebook too and
everyone was just like oh my god like
there's like a girl that sings like and
Lodi did at us so like the fact that I'm
able to actually it took a long time to
like get to where I am now obviously but
like the fact that like everything is
like like the sex show I had like hello
people from Lodi show up and like it's
just cool that I get to put my city on
the map even if like the world doesn't
know what Laura is like I got to fill my
first like actual like single single and
video in my hometown and like the fact
that it reached like out of the US like
Japan and China like so many people are
repost like posting it out there I'm
just like wow like my town is making it
like outside yeah what I said about Lodi
earlier I'm just kidding I love Laura no
Laura is cute like if you just want to
go for a day yeah if you hate reg I just
- that's where your apples come from
[ __ ] think about that yeah yeah it's
it's good not as cool just because like
we go to New York a lot and sometimes
I'm look on the menu like there's like
Lodi wine on the moon that's like that's
like that like hometown love right yes
my friends don't understand they go away
you bug in like rep Sacramento so much
yeah in town yeah I think like small
town people really appreciate where they
come from a lot I definitely do like it
definitely just like it built me and
coming from a small town definitely like
humbles me I feel like you're like you
might be they're super so I don't know I
don't know too many artists they came
out of Lodi not I'm the only one tiny
little statue of you right there with
[ __ ] water coming up
you know like that'd be sick like I want
to be that hometown hero like you
probably already are to a lot of young
people no man just passin ya here from a
small town to like you don't see that a
lot so it's hard for you to it's hard
for younger people to envision
themselves in the shoes that they want
to be in because people from their town
haven't done it like mm-hmm right so
it's it's it's inspiring for a lot of
people I think Sacramento has a has you
know it's coming up specifically with
these guys they're Sacramento right yeah
it's it's amazing to see what they've
done like I am when I went to their
studio I was just like damn yeah I mean
it blows my [ __ ] mind like it's
amazing to me just just to see it happen
yeah bro like even uh yeah we have a
friend named Phil you know he's he's the
the leader of the Jabbawockeez right
he's from Sacramento we went to the same
high school too grew up together and
then to have him walk around and people
just not so much the recognition but
they respect him in such a high way
blows my [ __ ] mind
mm-hmm right because he's he was an
originator of a certain dance down that
people [ __ ] that [ __ ] with so much and
even for you you might you you're on
that trajectory becoming that iconic in
your hometown yeah that's that must be
so [ __ ] humbling for you know it is
I'm it's just I'm super blessed your
best friend from back in the day you
[ __ ] up
you [ __ ] up you stupid [ __ ] oh my god
dude
you're so [ __ ] dumb man you're so
stupid
that's what you don't burn bridges dude
dumb and you could have you could have
been in a music video ho hate that girl
dude I don't even know where I [ __ ]
what's her [ __ ] name you're not gonna
say it but I'll say her name is [ __ ]
Nancy [ __ ] Nance No Esperanza [ __ ]
dollar they're like two gotta [ __ ]
[ __ ] hate this girl did I hate people
like that man what did you guys have a
falling-out though just curious when why
oh why um how she backstab you it was it
was actually it was church-related it
was because
ya know like this this like kind of
cross like this is this is like kind of
serious but like she didn't support my
music because it wasn't like of the Lord
like because I was doing I was doing
secular music and